hey guys dr. Burke here in this very
short video I'm going to talk about the
absolute worst protein powder that you
can consume alright can you take any can
you take well guess what it is now it's
not pea protein
it's not even whey protein it is the soy
protein isolate
that's the worst protein you can
possibly consume why because first of
all 95% of all soy is genetically
modified which means that it has residue
of an herbicide which is basically
Roundup Ready called glyphosate which is
a pretty deadly chemical and so when
they modify this genetically it can even
act like a something like an estrogenic
thing to even insects to so it's it's
going to raise your estrogen levels and
decrease your testosterone now women are
pretty much already estrogen dominant
and men don't need any more estrogen so
this will lower testosterone it's in the
diet shakes it's in the diet bars it's
in infant formula crazy it's in the
artificial vegan patties that fake meat
so you want to stay away from this
protein it's really hard on the liver
and plus it's not fermented fermented
like in tofu tempeh and mezzo this is
not fermented so that means it doesn't
digest well and it's going to be really
hard on your liver one day I am I was at
Whole Foods and I saw I saw these little
chicken little nugget things I said oh
that's pretty cool man to order I'm
gonna order some of those right and I
noticed when I bought them they were all
the same size and so you start eating
them I'm like this tastes like a weird
piece of chicken it was it was chicken
minute of soy protein isolates and I get
home I probably had two or three and my
whole right side of my liver was like in
pain so that was a perfect example or a
demonstration of what I'm not going to
do again
so I just wanted to mention this and so
put your comments below and thanks for
watching